gotta have the right attitude right guys
i i could have told i could have told
them that would happen but
you know what they're new to it speaking
of snow on this day
12 years ago today marks 12 years since
a record amount of snow fell on las
vegas you guys remember this
well the official amount was only 3.6
inches as many as 10
inches fell in some parts of the valley
like henderson
mount charleston reported 14 inches
and the welcome to las vegas sign just
saw
right around two to three inches there
you guys remember that
yeah i remember so many people went to a
desert breeze park
and just got like garbage lids or
anything they could find so they could
slide down the snow
and make snowmen because we knew it was
going to be gone the next day it was
just
awesome school was canceled everyone was
calling me asking if school was canceled
and i said i'm not the superintendent
but yes almost 8 inches to 10 inches of
snow
out where brian lives out there in
henderson and people just weren't used
to it brian it was it was
the craziest thing i remember sledding
down las vegas
no i'm kidding i wasn't living here yet
so i don't remember it
but if i did live here i would have gone
sledding on the strip
well if anybody knew how to drive in
snow it's brian coming from chicago guys
so we all know oh yeah i can do donuts
yeah okay eyes closed
yeah of course that didn't happen today
but we did get rain
and we finally broke that record dry
streak
ended today at 240 days since our last
measurable rate so actually last time we
had widespread rain like this
was april 20th that's how long it has
been 240 days
we picked up officially four hundredths
of an inch of rain so that means
officially yes
the record dry streak ends and this is a
record because the previous record was
150 days
we broke that record back on september
18th
50 degrees outside right now now we had
gusty winds earlier still a little
breezy right now from the north that
tells me that the cold front has
slid through and now those winds are
coming from the north
those winds have calmed down also for
those of you in henderson where we did
see gusts up to 35 in some locales even
40 in some
locations we're about four degrees
warmer than we were yesterday at this
time in the high 40s for you and
henderson
let's get to our neighborhoods right now
centennial hills 48 for you along with
sky canyon
providence nice chilly up there aliante
at 52 north las vegas 51
60 in sunrise mountain whitney ranch at
62-50 in henderson
mountains to edge at 46-49 currently for
anthem and outside of town also
chilly for you in sandy valley at 49
degrees over the hump
at 51.50 for boulder city and laflin
coming in at 52 degrees so
there's the rain right now is the
latest on the radar and like i said when
i said we had a shortened time window i
meant it because
look at this behind this now clearing
see that so really our chances for any
more showers tonight maybe a slight
chance of an isolated shower but nothing
like we just saw
within the last hour there's that low
moving off towards the east bringing all
that precip along with it but now that
front has slid through
behind that now we have the wind so
tomorrow we'll see those winds increase
again breezy winds from the north for
tomorrow
gusting up to 25 30 down at the lake now
this is for the morning hours the first
half of the day
because the latter half of the day those
winds will decrease even more we'll keep
on those slight isolated chances
for at least until the 11 o'clock hour
we go on for eight news at 11.
mostly cloudy and chilly 41 overnight
for the low our high for tomorrow
56 breezy and cooler we showed you those
winds
gusting between 20 to 30 miles per hour
meanwhile here is your extended forecast
now great looking weekend for the last
minute shopping
and take a look at next week back to the
mid 60s for the first
day of winter breezy for christmas eve
that's the most soccer weather update
we'll be back after this